as you might be able to tell the kind of
topper we're looking at today is you
relative frequency polygons which is a
mouthful which is why they have a very
short abbreviated name which seems to
have nothing to do it cumulative
frequency or polygons does anyone know
what's the other name for these starts
with an O it's a no guys that's right I
didn't know if they just made this up
because they were just sick of say
cumulative frequency polygon but there
you go
different date same thing okay now we're
gonna look at well how do you make these
things how do you draw them up how do
you construct them more importantly
there that's kind of just saying like
you've actually looked at the
construction of these before
we're sort of more focused on
interpretation the TechSoup tactually
doesn't look that much at interpretation
of these graphs so I have actually have
a separate worksheet here that I'm going
to give you but that's kind of got two
stages for today okay so right now we're
doing that construction bit and there
are four steps so we're gonna go through
it's really easy to construct it right
okay and it all begins with your data he
go ahead this is that starting point now
I might not get presented to you like
this but this is how we're gonna
presented to do the work so if you gotta
do a cumulative frequency polygon it
makes sense that step one is to work out
the cumulative frequencies right okay so
that that's what this CF column is about
now just to jog your memory
F for frequency how do we build
cumulative frequency off of frequency oh
good it's all just add about right so
you start with you right this is your
first value so there's nothing else to
add on to this you just write down three
that's easy okay now the cumulative
frequency of this group and this is
groups data that we're looking at the
cumulative frequency of this truth is
everyone in this group and everyone
below okay what I mean above here that
it's below in terms of value right so
there you go 18 plus 321
okay now as we go down you could keep on
adding up like three an 18 and then
three 1947 and then threes and 1847
someone we don't need to do all of those
numbers all over again because all of
these will be missed up up right so how
do we get to this one what do we add up
yeah good you can see there twenty or
forty seven and they sort of hold down
this mystery you get six eight okay
you're getting don't you memory home
let's let's just finish off the table
quickly 68 for thirty two hundred and
forty hundred twenty nice round number
okay so that was step one step one is
calculate the cumulative frequencies now
step two is where we come to this guy a
set of axes right now you want to uh
this is Neptune you want to put some
thought into your axes before you start
drawing it bless you and then you end up
with something which song you know
you've the values you've picked make
your graph very hard to draw okay so
first along the arm along this axis down
here this is going to be our high
dancers okay so we'll have our different
groups these guys okay we're gonna have
them along the bottom here now be the
wingtip group data they're two ways to
label these right I could find that this
both phone I could either use these on
tops and bottoms of the different groups
okay that's actually what I'm gonna do
in a second there is an alternative
though if there's group data
what else could I put down here good I
could say well the center of this class
will be 312 and the center of this class
will be 337 and on a blue moon rock okay
you will see both in equal measure
basically in this case I'm going to use
these numbers 300 325 and so on
so there's our horizontal axis okay now
you know how to end at 450 which is in
here because that's kind of the end
point of that last group all right no
problem now in order to construct your
vertical axis right it's going to go all
the way from 0 up to your cumulative
frequency right so this is our
cumulative frequency axis right everyone
does this differently
you've got a ruler there right so what
I'll probably do is say the top of your
graph write some arbitrary I don't know
how tall you've made your graph well you
want to end at 120 right less you so now
from there I'm just gonna divide it up
into chunks rather than say oh I'm gonna
make this 10 and then I'm going to go up
and uh-oh I ran out of space or uh-oh
I've only gone half way and I've gotten
behind something I need okay so if
that's what 20 you can get your ruler
out and do this but I have some 860
you'll be about there there are rats and
I can have the other intervals as well
that'll make this this about 30 you get
the idea I'm not gonna put all the rest
of the numbers there because it's just
gonna plug it all up but I will put in
my increments of 10 because then when I
draw these I'll have a rough idea of
where they'll fit okay so that would be
10 20 40 and 50
a hundred and a hundred into not bad
considering I just I just guessed that
y'all so much better my because you're
actually measuring things out